qual é o seu sonho
qual foi a primeira vez que você
respondeu o que você quer ser quando
crescer se você se lembra dessa resposta
você queria ser programador o engenheiro
médico professor talvez talvez aqui pra
você já ouviu falar em ataque
muitas crianças também nunca ouviram
falar e programador eu acho que quem
nunca ouviu falar em taquígrafo também
não queria ser daqui prova assim como as
crianças não queriam ser programadores
uma pessoa que vai anotar exatamente
tudo o que está falando tudo que você
está agindo qualquer pessoa redota
falando para conseguir sair tem que
escrever muito muito rápido
desse jeito ele parecendo um médico
escrevendo a receita média do que só a
formação decorreu depois mas é isso aí é
muito importante e acaba que assim com o
médico que consegue aos salários e às
vezes a motivação para você seguir uma
carreira talvez seja eu quero ser mesmo
porque eu vou ganhar muito dinheiro
um taquígrafo também chega ganhar o
mesmo salário de um médico num concurso
para o senado por exemplo
então será que essa é a verdadeira
motivação quando eu cheguei quando eu
cheguei na unifei eu cheguei vou falar
um pouco sobre a minha motivação sobre
esse sonho sobre o que me levou a isso
né
eu vim para onde foi em 2012
a unifei tinha quatro anos ela aqui em
itabira ela tinha quatro anos e ainda
estava nua numa situação em que não
tinha ainda alguns formados a maioria
dos engenheiros forma se com cinco anos
ou mães e com quatro anos ainda não
tinha dado há muito tempo mas com o
professor e pesquisador sempre gosta de
achar um diagnóstico do problema
já existia um os alunos tinham muita
retenção em cálculo que calcula uma
matemática básica engenharia e muitos
alunos repetiram essa disciplina muitos
alunos se desmotivam desistiu dos seus
cursos e isso era um problema um
problema imediato um problema de curto
prazo e é estranho né porque a gente
começa a matemática e falar oque
matemática dá pra entender e de repente
alguém em algum momento alguma coisa
acontece que é você deixa de gostar de
matemática por algum motivo não um mas
mesmo os engenheiros eles entravam na
faculdade e mesmo gostando de matemática
que normalmente engenheiro gosta de
matemática eles estavam sendo presos em
cálculo e aí eu é já como existe um
problema existe também uma proposta de
solução não talvez vou tecer taças uma
proposta vamos fazer cálculo zero porque
o problema é que em alvo os alunos que
entraram estão preparados ainda para
fazerem isso então o ensino médio não
resolver o problema deles então vamos
ensinar tudo que eles deviam aprender
ainda nem eu nem o ensino médio na
faculdade é em algum 0
vai ser um jeito de resolver todo o
problema escolar em um cms eles vão
conseguir
hoje cinco anos depois a gente já tem
uma noção que isso não deu muito certo
o aluno que tomava mundo em cálculo
também repetirá cálculo zero e aí isso
virou entrave porque os alunos que
passariam álbum agora tinham seis meses
a mãe para fazer 10 e aí isso akazawa as
outras matérias que dependiam de tal
comum nesse mesmo momento que eu cheguei
em 2012 é eu sou eu sempre gostei de
matemática sempre gostei muito de
computador desde a primeira vez que eu
vi foi amor à primeira vista e eu também
gostava de ensinar eu virei professor de
computação é e quando eu fui dar aula
para engenharia
a votação outro diagnóstico que eu fiz
foi que os alunos de engenharia de
computação que estavam quase formando a
maioria deles não gostava nada de
programar de fazer o código de fazer
software fazer programas
eles querem mexer só com hardware achava
o seguinte cientista da computação que
tem que saber programa
nós temos que fazer temos que fazer
equipamentos nós somos de rádio nós
somos engenharia de computação e pra mim
isso sempre soa estranho mas ao menos um
médico falasse olha eu tenho ro a sangue
não quero ver sangue mas eu vou ser
médico e aí eu falava se nossa mãe
em que momento será um aluno da
computação começou a ter esse pânico por
código e que só rádio aqui no brasil não
é tão comum
o engenheiro a tentação é conseguir um
emprego que vai mexer só conrado e mesmo
que consiga o software também vai ser
fácil é da necessidade de entendimento
dele e foi aí que eu falei não a gente
tem que mudar isso e eu pensei não vou
fazer alguma maneira que os alunos
queiram programado desde o aluno que
está entrando agora o calor o
ingressante até o aluno que está quase
se formando e foi aí que eu comecei uma
maratona de programação que a maratona
de programação
talvez vocês vão ter ouvido mas é uma
competição em dez problemas todos de
computação muito difíceis na sua maioria
em cada vez você acerta um problema você
você vê um prêmio um balão colorido
balão colorido e e acreditem aquilo pra
eles é um troféu e olha que conseguir um
balão branco
parabéns pra mim você ainda não
conseguiu em e esse balão colorido era
uma resposta rápida ao acerto dele toda
vez que há certezas nem um balão e ainda
em 2012 eu já consegui montar minha
primeira equipe de maradona maratonista
de programação não resolverem cinco
horas 12 problemas e ganhar os seus
balões e quem sabe ganhar o troféu mesmo
sendo os melhores de todos da competição
é isso resolveria de alguma maneira o
problema da computação agora os alunos
estavam mais interessados pelo menos que
taxe paulo de maratona e eles acabavam
protegendo contagiando os demais mas o
problema de cálculo seria resolvido a
curto prazo mesmo os alunos os próprios
alunos da maratona falar nossa é
programa é tão legal a gente podia levar
isso pro - ensino fundamental
já pensou se um aluno do ensino
fundamental aprender a aprender a
programar ano já chega na faculdade
sabendo mais que a gente ea gente falou
é porque mão
isso talvez resolva a longo prazo esse
problema que a gente tem de curto prazo
de os alunos não saberem matemática e aí
a gente foi para a maratona não só de
programação não lhe fez com os nossos
alunos
a gente tentou fazer esse projeto de
ensinar alunos desde criancinhas desde
os 12 anos o programa e foi aí que a
gente foi agente compartilhar o mesmo
espaço no bairro amazonas com o pólo uab
e eu fiquei indignada procurar essas
pessoas que trabalhavam no colo
é pra falar com elas que ela já tinha um
projeto de que tinha uma parceria de
ensino ensino integral então em contra
turno escolar à tarde os alunos iam
fazer um projeto e eu fui contar da
minha proposta
olha a gente está querendo ensinar
lógica e programação para as crianças e
assim o caso muito bem
o projeto foi muito abraçado com
abraçado pelo surpreendeu em duas
semanas
ele veio de uma idéia era uma prática a
gente não sabe de nada só pensávamos que
a gente receber que a gente ensinar
na primeira aula quando a gente foi
ensinar programarem que passou alguns
problemas de lógica mais para a parte de
matemática antes de ensinar programar
para ver o que era e eu lembro como se
fosse ontem de uma aluna falando
a professora não quero ver nada disso
não
eu estou aqui porque isso aqui é reforço
eu sei amanhã senhor que é reforço e
reforço é ruim eu não aprendo nada na
escola porque eu vou aprender alguma
coisa com vocês vão ver a mesma coisa de
novo eu não aprendi uma vez não vou
aprender de novo eu falei olha o que eu
vou ensinar você estava na escola sua
mão você já viu alguma vez uma programar
fazer um programa de computador igual
vezes você vê não é você fazer isso
nunca me ensinaram ao mundo então não
tem como ser reforço se a primeira
pessoa que você está vendo aí ela me deu
a chance de tentar em sinal a junto com
meus monitores né então é os
maratonistas programação eram os
professores desses alunos da escola
fundamental é e eles começaram a fazer
vários projetos do tipo de projeto que
eles faziam normalmente era relacionado
à dor
a escola nem dão sempre eles vinham
fazendo os projetos como esse aí é
justamente no local eles faziam e eles
fazem os atores que eram no caso eles
mesmos
todo o código de programação diferente
do que foi visto ali e esse formato de
programação foi justamente porque no
mesmo ano que a gente começou o projeto
começaram a ter ao redor do mundo é
incentivos a todo mundo aprender a
modificar até obama entrou nessa então
todo mundo tinha que fazer um código por
pelo menos uma hora e isso nos inspirou
e até nos ajudou muito com algumas
ferramentas mais lúdicas
então começamos a fazer alguns jogos e
trabalhar com as crianças de uma maneira
que elas faziam por exemplo um jogo pra
capturar escravos na áfrica porque eles
estavam se estudando escravidão e eles
queriam representar isso de alguma
maneira
quando esses alunos foram representar a
escravidão
eles eram lembra brasileiro e eles
queriam tinham interesse porque eles
sempre se achavam determinados a
dispensar nossa é eu sou descendente de
escravos eu sou inferior é assim como
muitos alunos agente que teve essa essa
surpresa que eles tinham muito essa
questão assim muito rotulados eles
controlavam muito então eu pensava
muitas vezes nós somos incapazes né como
eu tinha falado que eles são é alunos
que iam para reforço
então esse reforço eles se achavam eles
se achavam incapazes
então a questão de motivação eles não
tinham nenhuma eles eram os piores
alunos eles eram os alunos bagunceiros
os alunos acreditados por todos os
professores e pior por eles mesmos
e aí eles começaram a se enxergar de
outra forma
eles começaram a se enxergar nesse caso
da escravidão como possíveis
descendentes de reis porque maior quando
eles foram tentar construir o programa
eles estudavam isso eles descobriram que
alguns escravos que foram trazidos para
o brasil na áfrica era o rei e isso pra
eles mudou muito a autoestima então essa
questão da catarse foi muito forte no em
todo o projeto e isso trouxe a todo
mundo todos os meus maratonistas da
unifei que foram é os monitores o
conhecimento deles não tinham uma
realidade de cadeira que eles não
conviviam com ela e isso mudou muito
todo mundo a as aulas que a gente dê
fase então era só história matemática
não era sua lógica e até pra educação
física e eles mesmos faziam as suas
coisas e outras formas de jogos para
ajudar e eles melhoraram a escola e aí
ia para a partir de metodologia né
oprah outras partes e realmente e
isso não não tinha muita é muito foco de
só programar era sempre aplique o seu
conhecimento é o que você está vendo na
escola para programar porque a
programação tem esse poder
interessante de ligar qualquer profissão
ea qualquer matéria falava que não e
isso fez com que os alunos melhorarem
como um todo a ponto de que no final do
primeiro ano
vários depoimentos mais um espaço
específico foi o reconhecimento das
escolas que veio na seguinte forma é
nossa mas os alunos que estavam
precisando de fazer um reforço escolar
que fizeram o projeto agora sabem mais
do que os nossos alunos é que não há que
são ótimos alunos que são notar é
possível isso aí é uma punição a gente
precisa que esses melhores alunos tenham
a mesma oportunidade e eu concordo meu
objetivo era que todos os alunos
pudessem ter essa oportunidade todo
mundo que quer fazer a programação
não importa se é considerado o melhor
aluno o pior aluno me importa com o
rótulo que ele tenha porque pra mim do
mesmo jeito que você não nasceu a vender
uma amarração sapato
você não aprende no máximo aprendendo a
programação não chegou e falou assim
belezas aqui meu código e aí não importa
se é o melhor aluno o pior aluno todo
mundo entre igual a todo mundo entra 10
da programação e todo mundo vai aprender
juntos e eles me perguntaram como é que
a gente vai fazer com o projeto vai ter
todo mundo deveria se eu sempre falei é
senão todo mundo é igual a ninguém sabe
programa ea partir desse momento se no
primeiro ano foi mais para essa linha de
é fazer com as disciplinas segundo a
gente começou a adicionar outros
elementos como por exemplo é economia de
água como também
literatura então eles estudaram livro o
homem que calculava que tinha muita
lógica e foi isso desenvolveu muito o
raciocínio deles
bom é isso é a questão eu contei um
pouco do projeto e assim como vocês é
podem se perguntar e aí o cálculo que
aconteceu com o cálculo foi mais ou
menos a mesma linha a primeira tentativa
não deu certo mas hoje a gente está
pensando hoje se pensa muito em usar uma
forma de motivar não diretamente com o
ensino do básico
isso é falar que ela nem capazes de
falar que o aluno não tem capacidade de
mudar mas mostrando pra ele o que é que
aquilo que está na base onde vai chegar
e do mesmo jeito que a programação
envolveu todo mundo e mesmo os alunos
que tinham dificuldade é muito grande em
leitura começaram a querer ler livros
inclusive livros bem difíceis justamente
porque não achava que ia valer nada para
a vida deles
a partir desse momento é tudo começa a
fazer mais sentido quando você acha um
objetivo acham fundamento acham sentido
nesse é pra que você está vendo isso e
aquilo deixa de ser a eu tô querendo
passar né quando você não acha o
objetivo não haja fundamento você tem
que passar e aquilo passe porque não
sofrimento na sua vida e não que você
faça por aquilo experiência aquilo outro
trabalho também é justamente a aplicação
de lógica e ficarão tanto tão encantados
que pra ele programação parecia mágico e
foi justamente esse programa era uma
mágica pra adivinhar qual como você
escolheu
eu penso muito nessa questão do futuro é
se você aprendeu é de uma maneira que às
vezes não te motiva
isso pode ser
sim o obstáculo é o projeto aprender
muito com ele não bem ser simplesmente é
o ensino de programação para o alô
a programação é o fim eu não quero
formar formar programadores
apesar que isso seja também o objetivo
do mesmo jeito que eu faço aqui uma
pergunta pra vocês o que você quer ser
quando crescer eu já a gente chegou a
perguntar isso pra eles e ninguém sabia
o que era programação após a primeira
vez de um ano é vendo o fazendo parte do
projeto
alguns alunos queriam sim ser
programadores e mais o terceiro ano do
projeto
alguns alunos eram alunos né eles eram
da escola de ensino fundamental
eles passaram a ser monitoradas então já
está conseguido preparar um novo nível
né
um aluno que recebia aula do projeto a
ser professor do projeto
eu acho que é isso que a gente tem que
fazer você já tinha ouvido falar em
taquigrafia
isso motivou você se você mostrar uma
coisa nova por outras pessoas como
unifei que ele não conhecia e isso pode
ser uma nova realidade então mostrem
para as pessoas apresentem novas coisas
novas realidades das pessoas e quem sabe
essa realidade pode ser realidade delas
ou uma nova realidade para vocês
obrigado